you want to be Beyonce bleed like
Beyonce you want to be LeBron
bleed like LeBron like this notion that
it's going to be easy to be an all-time
great in anything are you
kidding me enough I sacrificed
my entire childhood I worked every day
of my life like I'm happy but
like I got how do people not
understand difficulties are gonna be
there everyone's looking at your son
right now who's in America who's a
soccer player and it's like oh lucky
awesome good for him all this stuff do
they want to go to Germany at 15 and
have that culture shock or do
they want to go to the prom I'll never
forget you know those first few months
you know and just not allowing him to
make an excuse suck it up get up in the
morning if this is what you want this is
how it's going to be people's actions do
not match the Ambitions coming out of
their mouth